[Music]
these bubbles in the Baltic Sea flared
up after explosions on the North stream
gas pipeline since September 2022
the incident prompted several
International investigations Western
officials initially accused Russia of
sabotage but Moscow denied this
now more details of the probes are
starting to emerge the German prosecutor
announced that they had searched a
rental yacht that was possibly linked to
the attack on the pipelines they also
said a pro-ukrainian group may have been
responsible but Ukrainian officials
denied any involvement
so here's what we know so far about the
explosions that hit some of Europe's
most important Pipelines
the Nordstrom and Nordstrom 2 pipelines
were built to transfer gas from Russia
to Europe a Russian gas Giant's gas prom
stopped delivery through North stream in
August 2022 saying the pipes needed
repairs
North stream 2 was built but wasn't up
and running yet because Germany stopped
its certification just before Russia's
invasion of Ukraine
then in September 2022 the pipelines
were damaged in explosions
Germany Sweden and Denmark the three
countries closest to the incident
launched separate investigations into
the cause
early findings said the blasts were
deliberate and caused leaks in four
places
and the investigations looked at the
possibility of Russia as the instigator
Moscow has repeatedly denied any
involvement
in early March German prosecutors said
that two months earlier investigators
searched a yacht and found traces of
explosives on board we've managed to
locate it in the north of Germany it's a
very beautiful white Sleek Leisure boat
that has five cabins and and can
comfortably sleep 11 people
investigators believe the vessel set
sail from reports in Northern Germany on
September 6.
around September the 7th and made a pit
stop and week on the island of urugan
also Northern Germany they're I think
part of the crew came on board and they
loaded the boat with food and other
provisions
and then from then uh there's a bit of a
gap and then the boat re-emerges on the
16th of September on the Danish island
of Kristen Zoo which is close to the
area where the north stream pipelines
were attacked
German officials said a group of people
rented the boat some of them presented
Ukrainian passports that may have been
forged
tracks
well we don't know however is who these
people were what is exactly their
relationship to Ukraine if they were
ukrainians and whether or not they have
any relationship to the Ukrainian
government or any kind of formal
Authority
Ukrainian officials denied any
involvement
that's totally against our own interests
Russia's Presidents had accused what he
called Anglo-Saxon powers of blowing up
the pipelines and the Kremlin said
Western Nations rejected its request to
join their investigations one thing that
we know for for a fact that these
investigators do not believe any more
that Russia was behind
German investigators are also looking at
whether the boat was part of a larger
Mission or a false flag operation
designed to divert attention from the
real culprits we'll see where this leads
but at the present time it doesn't seem
we have more clarity it seems we have
even more layers of obscurity and
mystery adding to this kind of huge
puzzle
the leaks highlighted concerns about the
safety of critical energy infrastructure
in Europe it demonstrates the importance
of protecting our critical undersea
infrastructure as for the damaged pipes
there's no indication that they'll be
repaired anytime soon
foreign